musa is interested in the relationship
between hours spent studying and
caffeine consumption among students at
his school he randomly selects 20
students at his school and records their
caffeine intake in milligrams and the
amount of time studying in a given week
here is a computer output from a least
squares regression analysis on his
sample
assume that all conditions for inference
have been met what is the 95 percent
confidence interval for the slope of the
least squares regression line so if you
feel inspired pause the video and see if
you can have a go at it otherwise we'll
we'll do this together
okay so let's first remind ourselves
what's even going on so let's visualize
the regression
so our horizontal axis or our x-axis
that would be our caffeine
intake in milligrams and then our y-axis
or our vertical axis that would be the i
would assume it's in hours so time
time studying
and musa here he randomly selects 20
students and so for each of those
students he sees how much caffeine they
consumed and how much time they spent
studying and plots them here and so
there'll be 20 data points 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20. he inputs these data points into
a computer in order to fit a least
squares regression line and let's say
the least squares regression line looks
something
like this and a least squares regression
line comes from trying to minimize the
square distance between the line and all
of these points and then this is giving
us information on that least squares
regression line and the most valuable
things here if we really want to help
visualize or understand the line is what
we get in this column the constant
coefficient tells us essentially what is
the y-intercept here so 2.544
and then the coefficient on the caffeine
this is a one way of thinking about well
for every incremental increase in
caffeine how much does this time
studying increase
or you might recognize this as the slope
of the least squares regression line so
this is the slope and this would be
equal to 0.164
now this information right over here it
tells us how well our least squares
regression line fits the data r squared
you might already be familiar with it
says how much of the variance in the y
variable is explainable by the x
variable if it was 1 or 100 that means
all of it could be explained and it's a
very good fit if it was 0 that means
none of it can be explained it'll be a
very bad fit
capital s this is the standard deviation
of the residuals and it's another
measure of how much these data points
vary from this regression line
now this column right over here is going
to prove to be useful for answering the
question at hand this gives us the
standard error of the coefficient and
the coefficient that we really care
about the statistic that we really care
about is the slope of the regression
line and this gives us the standard
error for the slope of the regression
line you could view this as the estimate
of the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the slope of
the regression line remember we took a
sample of 20 folks here and we
calculated a statistic which is the
slope of the regression line every time
you do a different sample you will
likely get a different slope and this
slope is an estimate of some true
parameter in the population this would
sometimes also be called the standard
error of the slope of the least squares
regression line now these last two
columns you don't have to worry about in
the context of this video
this is useful if you were saying well
assuming that there is no relationship
between caffeine intake and time
studying what is the associated t
statistics for the statistics that i
actually calculated and what would be
the probability of getting something
that extreme or more extreme assuming
that there is no association assuming
that for example the actual slope of the
regression line is zero and this says
well the probability if we would assume
that is actually quite low it's about a
one percent chance that you would have
gotten these results if there truly was
not a relationship between caffeine
intake and time studying but with all of
that out of the way let's actually
answer the question
well to construct a confidence interval
around a statistic you would take the
value of the statistic that you
calculated from your sample so 0.164
and then it would be plus or minus a
critical t value and then this would be
driven by the fact that you care about a
95 percent confidence interval and by
the degrees of freedom and i'll talk
about that in a second and then you
would multiply that times the standard
error of the statistic and in this case
the statistic that we care about is the
slope and so this is 0.057
times
0.057 and the reason why we're using a
critical t value instead of a critical z
value is because our standard error of
the statistic is an estimate we don't
actually know the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution
so the last thing we have to do is
figure out what is this critical t value
you can figure it out using either a
calculator or using a table i'll do it
using a table and to do that we know
what the degrees of freedom well when
you're doing this with a regression
slope like we're doing right now your
degrees of freedom are going to be the
number of data points you have
minus 2. so our degrees of freedom are
going to be 20 minus 2 which is equal to
18. i'm not going to go into a bunch of
depth right now it actually is beyond
the scope of this video for sure as to
why you subtract 2 here but just so that
we can look it up on a table this is our
degrees of freedom
so we care about a 95 confidence level
that's equivalent to having a two and a
half percent tail on either side and our
degrees of freedom it's 18
so our critical t value is 2.101
and so
our 95 percent confidence interval is
going to be 0.164
plus or minus our critical t value 2.101
times the standard error of the
statistic
times i'll just put in parentheses 0.05
and you could type this into a
calculator if you wanted to figure out
the exact values here but the way to
interpret a 95 confidence interval is
that 95 of the time that you calculate a
95 confidence interval it is going to
overlap with the true value of the
parameter that we are estimating